hi guys as you might have seen i created
my first
short film using unreal engine
and i thought i'd take this time just to
reflect on
how that process was what i learnt
during my time making the cinematic
and what i would do differently now
because there is
a lot that i would do differently now
for those of you who might not be aware
unreal engine is a games engine it's
made by epic games who also made
fortnite
which also uses unreal engine however
it's becoming increasingly more
popular to see game engines be used in
the film space as well which
extremely excites me if you've been
following me for a while you know that i
have been
in this weird middle ground between
loving film and loving game development
and now
that it's coming together it's extremely
exciting one of the
most coolest ways that i've seen it used
in
a film scenario is with the mandalorian
and they made real-time rendered 3d
scenes
using these gigantic led screens so that
the actors
could act within small spaces but
really think that they were on like
tatooine or something like that the 3d
scenes could even move due to the camera
angles
or how the actors were moving and
responding to the environment and if
it just blew my mind you could watch a
whole documentary on disney plus but
what did i learn while making my
cinematic i
certainly did not make anything as grand
as what the mandalorian has done
no but uh i made something cool
and i'm proud of it if you haven't seen
it already watch forgive me now
my horror short film because there will
be spoilers ahead
[Music]
okay are you back great thanks for
watching by the way
really appreciate everyone that has done
and left me loads of feedback
i always appreciate the feedback i will
start off by saying
this project was a year-long process
or perhaps even a bit more than that
actually because
it took me a long time to write the
short story and then it
took me a long time to work with jamie
the producer
at horizon productions who created an
amazing soundtrack and then
it was on to the nitty-gritty getting
everything into unreal engine so i'm
going to touch on that today but there
was way more to
that project number one set up your
project's exposure settings or actually
just look at your
settings anyway and check that
everything's
in shape i spent an awful long time
trying to get the right look and feel of
my environment
what i did was i was playing around with
the lights
i was creating it how i wanted it to be
and then i realized that throughout my
cameras and my scene weird
dark and light patches were happening
and i wasn't sure why and then i
realized way way way way way too late
that my project had auto exposure on
and that was automatically updating the
light in my scene
derp jumped up all you have to do is go
to the project settings look for auto
exposure
click it off and then reboot your
project and you're good to go
when you're making a cinematic it's best
to just make as many things manual as
possible
because you don't have to worry about a
player going in and
interacting with the world and the world
having to adapt to that
you have full control over what the
viewer is going to see
so you want to make sure that it looks
exactly how you want it to look
number two i would say test the size of
your map
as you're making your environment in a
level
you're dragging and dropping in your 3d
models you're placing everything
together
making sure it looks good you've
probably got your sky box don't do what
i did
don't get to the end of that process
where you're pretty happy with the
placement of all of your
your assets and your models and then
bring in
your point lights your spotlights your
wrecked lights
and your particle systems and realize
that
your level is far too big
for the lights to even register
it was crazy i put it on its largest
size and brightness
and i saw no light and then i realized
it's because
my scene was huge and the lights
just could not compensate for that so i
did manage to find a workaround
all you have to do is create an empty
actor
put it into your scene go into your
world outliner
and then attach everything in your level
to this empty actor and then you can
just
change the scale of that but it's still
not great
don't make the same mistake that i did
but that is your work around if you do
so it's not a big deal
number three use asics from
asics number three use
assets from the marketplace i cannot say
this
enough as a solo developer
you cannot do everything by yourself
and you should not expect yourself to
either if you can do that then you are a
genie yes and i don't know where you
find the time but you do you
boo most of us cannot do that
when creating a scene even if you're not
actually making a game and you're just
making a cinematic
you still need 3d models textures
animations particle system
normal maps audio and so
so so much more and it's very
overwhelming even just to think about
the amount of work
that goes into creating a digital world
don't do it all go to the unreal
marketplace
or even just look on websites online for
3d models and
animations and things like that you can
you can buy them there are some that you
can use for free
and you just have to credit them unreal
marketplace has
uh free and paid for assets that you can
use and they also
showcase free packs every month
i would like to give a massive shout out
right now to chameleon
which is a post-processing pack and no
we are not sponsored by them but they
are so
freaking cool it took me so long to find
an
art style that i liked because i wanted
to have this weird art style
that was kind of brush strokey kind of
reminded me of reading a book
so as you get closer you can see the
detail as you get further away
things start to get more paint like
which i i quite like
i found chameleon and it gives you so
many options for how you would like your
scene to look
it has styles from a cartoonistic style
to more kind of grungy worn down styles
for say a horror game
and they even have camera effects such
as
shaking or sci-fi pulses
they have so much in there and i managed
to tweak around
for probably days just to get this
this perfect perfect look that i was
really searching for and i couldn't have
done it without the chameleon packs
though
link in the description down below okay
number four i can't talk to you about a
cinematic without talking to you about
cameras what cameras do you use well
i used all cine actor cameras
is that what they're called cine camera
actors basically the same thing
so these cameras give you a little bit
more control
over what it's doing uh mainly over the
focus
so where you want it to be focused you
can also
have tracking on it so you can actually
have it
look at an actor and stay looking at
that actor so even if you're moving it
manually it will still be
tracking looking at a certain point that
you've told it to look at
which is pretty cool pretty useful i
actually didn't do that in this
movie short film whatever the hell it is
throwaway piece of work
but because i wanted more control i
guess i never really needed it to look
at a certain
point but i can imagine it would be very
useful
especially in games see if you have a
kind of cut scene where you're talking
to another character and you want the
camera to show
both the player and the character
they're talking to but you don't want to
manually
hand craft those scenes you can just
run a piece of script that makes the
camera look at
each of the characters um that would be
really useful
and when you are arranging your camera's
focus there is a draw debug plane which
is basically a
purple plane that shows you the exact
point
in which you are focusing on
and that's extremely useful i was doing
this all on a
laptop oh that's my chair my laptop is
behind there
and uh every now and then i couldn't see
very well so being able to focus on the
purple plane
allowed me to see where the focus was
top tip though do
untick this debug plane because when you
render your scene
it renders the planes as well and you
don't want that
so make sure that you make them not
visible again
once you have set up your focus point
i'll talk a little bit about sequencer
now but we'll go into more depth with it
a bit later on in the video
but to add these cameras to your
sequencer you can set it up under
cinematics in the toolbar
there'll be a little plus icon next to
the very
top timeline and then you can bind your
existing camera to that
you'll then have access to that camera
within the sequencer itself
and you'll be able to track things such
as its location which you will
definitely
be wanting to do one thing that i would
also note is that
it doesn't automatically update your
camera
if you move it in editor it's very
annoying what you have to do
is go to the point in your sequence
where you want to be
move the camera where you want it to be
then go back to sequencer
and make sure that you click on your
keyframes to store
that location so many times i would move
my camera expect it to auto create
the keyframes and it doesn't and then i
move again and i've lost it
it's very annoying to view the sequencer
timeline in real time
you can click the little camera icon
next to your camera cuts in the
sequencer
and this will lock the viewport to what
your cameras
are showing also when you have a camera
selected it will show you
its view and a little window at the
bottom
right and you can pin this so that it's
always active which is
really useful when you want to move
actors in and around
the scene of your camera number five
my bright idea to include video so i'm
not much of a 3d modeler as i haven't
done it in a very long time
and i have actually never done a 3d
animation before
so i couldn't rely on these skills to
create motion
or emotion in my scene
so instead i thought well what am i good
at
making videos so i figured i would put
videos into my scene and this opened up
a lot more possibilities but also led
to many many problems okay so i'm going
to try and walk you through
my thought process behind this and also
how i inserted the videos into my
project
but a lot of it was trial and error so
i'm sorry if it's a bit rambly
firstly i needed a way to have
one cohesive blueprint that would output
multiple videos at certain points
within the video render because the idea
of having multiple videos just running
on a loop
while my poor little computer tried to
render
an almost half an hour cinematic really
made me feel uneasy so i thought if i
could just have one actor that would
change what video it was showing and
perhaps have multiple instances of that
then that would be more performant
i thought she says so even just the
process
of putting a video into your level
is a little bit lengthy you need a
file media source and then a media
player
and then a media texture basically
the media source is fed into the media
player
which is then fed into the media texture
which
is then used to create a media material
wow
so many things just for one
media output it's crazy i also decided
to create a
media playlist to have my wonderful idea
of one actor playing multiple videos
because
it could be ran through the same
playlist and then the playlist
would point to my media player so
instead of my media player only playing
one video it would play this whole
playlist
a bug that i found though in doing this
is that every time
i opened up my scene i realized that i
was losing reference
to the videos and i couldn't actually
see them in the editor and this is
because
the media player every time it was
closed
had actually lost reference to the
file source or in my case the media
playlist
so i couldn't see that preview but every
time
i reopened it and i double clicked to
re-establish it with the playlist then
boom everything in my scene using that
media texture that was ran from that
media player showed the wonderful video
again
oh gosh i hope this isn't too uh crazy
and
i hope it's making sense i had major
major major issues with frame rate
for some reason my videos were playing
far far
too fast i googled this and found out i
am
certainly not the only person that gets
this problem
apparently it's okay in game it's just
that when you try to render out
a cinematic video the camera renders
a lot slower than what the video plays
so when it shows back the video it's not
how you expect it to look because even
when you play an editor the videos play
at the correct speed but when you render
out a cinematic and watch it back your
videos are like
double the speed that you expected them
to be
very annoying the workaround i found
online
was that i had to make my videos into a
series of images
and play them like that which i am not
going to do because i think my laptop
would explode
and the project would be huge so
instead i just exported slow motion
versions of the video
and used those instead and they came out
looking kind of normal-ish speed
some people in the in the comments of
the video actually noticed the speed
so i created a blueprint actor which
only held a plane
and this plane had a material of the
video material that linked
to my media playlist even this didn't
work how i expected it to
i had made functions that would trigger
different videos to play and then to
loop
and this was working fine but i expected
that if i had
multiple of these blueprint actors let's
call them plane one
and plane two two planes that should
play
videos and i expected that if i ran
functions on plane two and not on plane
one
that plane two would show a different
video
and plane one would stay at its default
video
that was not the case because the media
player seems to only have
one render output so if you have
multiple
instances of that same blueprint using
that same
media material back to that media player
playlist there's only going to be one
output so what happens if you change one
video
on plane two and not on plane one the
video changes
on both the planes i feel like i
explained that really badly
basically there's one render output okay
guys but that's okay
because luckily i'm making a cinematic
and you're not going to see
two planes in the same scene in summary
after all of this
i had my blueprint i had my plane with
my media material
and i had my functions set up to change
the videos
and these were going to be called from
sequencer itself
more on that later number six
keying green screen through the
materials
and luckily this one was simpler than i
had originally thought my videos were
green screen so i wanted to take away
this green screen
and have just the faces and whatever was
happening in front of it
be directly into the 3d scene itself now
i am no environment artist
i am no texture artist so i'm not going
to sit here
and try to say that i knew exactly what
i was doing because
youtube and google certainly
helped me but i will put on the screen
what i did to make this material once i
had created this material i could then
create material instances
and tweak the values that i have put
here like
the edge offset and the color gain and
things like that
this meant that i could better key each
individual video if i needed to do so
number seven using sprite animations
this was really fun i decided to use
hand-drawn sprites to give
the storybook feel and bring that to
life a little bit more
so i actually use rotoscope animation i
created these sprites in
photoshop and all i did for this was
import the
video frames to layers of the videos i
had taken for
different movements and then every six
frames also
i'd create a new layer that was a png
and i could just trace over the top of
the movement that i wanted
to create as a drawn sprite
then i could remove the video layers
leaving only the drawn ones and turn
these into a sprite sheet i actually
used a layers to sprite
javascript photoshop script what a
sentence
and it was developed by jesse freeman so
i will leave that in the
description down below so creating the
material for this meant
using the flipbook node in unreal engine
again keeping in mind that i would make
multiple instances
of this so i could change the column
number the row number and the speed of
the split book
i love the look of the sprites in the 3d
scene i think it worked really well
ah it's getting a bit um a bit
long a bit a bit long just a tiny bit
long
number eight editing animation
sequences this is where i went
completely wrong and i really
really wish hindsight is a beautiful
thing that i
had just used my brain just a little bit
more remember when i told you that i'm
no animator
well i didn't lie i'm not
and i'm sure if you look at the 3d
animation
in the short film you'll be like
yes
so what i did for the video
was that i saw the unreal engine had a
3d
people scan pack which again i'll put in
the description down below
it was free so i thought perfect amazing
3d people free too thanks unreal
marketplace
and they came with ready-made animations
to use
with these 3d models unfortunately the
animations
didn't really work for the kind of
horror vibe i was going for
so i decided to tweak them because how
hard could animation be right i opened
up the animation sequence
for these 3d models and i pressed the
big plus key
and all i did was look for the different
bones that i wanted to change
move them manually rotate them around a
bit
uh using the timeline as well and then
key in the new positions for them if it
ends up
not looking like the best animation in
the world because hey oh i'm not
animated
it'll look kind of creepy i mean if i
saw that guy
looking walking towards me like this i
think i'd be kind of scared
in hindsight i would have actually gone
to the website
where i got the 3d people pack from
realized that i could have gotten
an fbx version of the models
and then i could have put them into
mixamo
and i could have gotten a variety of
animations from that amazing
wonderful site but i didn't do that so
um
but again i was able to create that
uncanny valley ambience so
it's a design choice not a flaw
of course not a flaw let's talk about
sequencer
we're finally at sequencer number nine
we're talking about sequencer
sequencer is where you will do
absolutely everything
in your cinematic it is the premiere pro
it is the the film um
what are other film editing softwares
i move the it is where you have
all of your assets all of your cameras
transition
you get a faded and a fade out and
that's it but that's still a transition
and you get your um audio as well
and this is where you can edit it i
found it really intuitive actually if
you've used like after effects or
anything like that before because it
uses keyframes
so it was relatively simple to get used
to
and work with once you have the
sequencer open you can manually add
actors to track from your scene
using the green add actor button is that
what it says no it's a green
track button or alternatively
you can go straight into your scene in
your editor click on whatever you want
to add into your sequencer
and look down through the options in the
details panel
and there'll be a little it's like a
little script icon
and you click that and then it
automatically inserts the actor
and that information that you want to be
keyed
into sequencer so that could be like
it's visibility
it's scale it's material
anything like that and then once an
actor has been added into the sequencer
you can even open that up and track its
individual components yes there is so
much that you can track in the sequence
it's actually amazing
they even have their own inherited
switch material
and the coolest thing that i learnt
while using sequencer is that you can
trigger events
with the event track i was able to have
control over the exact frame
where i wanted my functionality to
happen on that specific blueprint actor
i'm going to attempt to take you through
my shoddy
setup of a blueprint actor
for my video actor that i was talking
about earlier
and how i triggered this through the
sequencer event
when creating these sequencer events it
will ask you to bind it
to a function that is available within
that actor
so what i did in my video playing
blueprint
was i made individual functions
for all of the videos in the playlists
this is probably a really long way of
doing it but
it's what i did each function actually
led to
the same second function which was
switching the media
called switch media these would be
called through the sequencer so i knew
when creating my sequencer events which
video i
wanted to call the switch media function
would then update the
media material which actually was a
public variable and i could change that
within the sequencer itself
i should have really put a check here so
i wasn't doing it every time but
whatever
then i could set the current playlist to
be that integer that i had just fed
through
and i did this through using the open
playlist index node
some of you might have noticed i had
another function there
and this was a very hacky function that
just allowed me
to loop through each video and not
the whole playlist it's very hacky and
it has a delay
so i'm not very proud of it but i had to
put it in there all it does is just
binds to the end of the video that plays
and then does a little delay so it makes
sure not to start playing the next video
and then it replays the whole thing
again don't look at it it's not my
finest piece of work
okay so when you start using sequencer
events you want to make sure that
they're actually working right you want
to make sure they're getting called
and that your blueprints are running
okay or your code if you're
a programmer you can't do this in editor
you need to
run it to actually see that everything
is firing
to do this is really simple all you need
to do is make sure that your sequencer
plays
on begin play when you press play on the
game
what will play is going to be the
sequencer that you have just set up
so you can open your level blueprint and
create
a variable that points to the sequencer
that you
have just created and then create a
level sequence player
and feed that in there and then play
give me a call if you want me to teach
blueprints
and finally here are my export
settings i thought you might want to see
them
took me a little a little tinker in just
to
understand what the export settings
were all about which ones work best for
me
i really implore you to please
make some test renders first
and while you do this you can use
compression that
will really speed up the process when
using compression
zero will be the highest compression and
lowest quality
and 100 will be the highest quality and
lowest compression and what i actually
really love
about these export settings is right
down the very bottom
under the animation tab you can actually
have
warm-up frames and delays even before
the warm-up
this allows some time just to run any
particles that you might have
in your scene any animations to start
playing
just so that as soon as your camera
starts to
record it's going to get your level
in the best way possible and a sneaky
sneaky 11
yeah you thought we were at the end but
we went and i also thought i was at the
end and it would definitely was not
i actually tidied up a lot of this in
premiere pro this
is mainly because of the lack of
transitions available
and i felt it made it look less
professional hard cuts are great
don't get me wrong but sometimes it's
nice to have
some differences in transitions and also
titles as well this also allowed me to
not have to render out the audio with my
video which
saved my render time a lot doing it out
of unreal engine
and it already took quite a few hours
but after that was all done it was all
done
and it was out and put up on youtube and
out for you guys to watch and for me to
ponder over so quickly
what would i change for next time well
what i did
was very much experimental in this first
cinematic i
kind of went overboard with the amounts
of things that unreal
engine was giving me to play with which
is a lot of things
and i totally lost my vision
i was talking to you a bit earlier about
how i wanted it to be
like a storybook and have storybook
feels and kind of painted vibes and
i really agree with my choice on using
sprite animation but i don't understand
why
i couldn't just stick to that why did i
have to do that
with the videos with some 3d animation i
think it would have been
a lot more unique and a lot more
stylized if i had picked one and stuck
to it also having a storyboard
just helps anyway it helps to set up the
shots set up the camera
the camera angles that you might want
the types of scenes that you are going
to create
i was doing everything on the fly this
is also because i didn't want to create
a storyboard because i wasn't sure what
i was able to do
within unreal engine so it makes sense
but in the future now that i do know
i need to be doing some really good
storyboards
really detailed storyboards that's what
i should have said
uh good is subjective and stick to them
i need to be tidier i need to be a
tinier developer
see this comes naturally to me when i'm
in a workplace with multiple other
people i think if i know
other people are going to see my work i
inherently i'm tidier i guess it's like
if you know someone is going to come
around your house especially if they're
a family member
you make sure your house is tidy you
make sure
that they're not going to scorn you for
it but when you're working on your own
stuff your own personal projects or if
you have your house to yourself
hey in lockdown no one's coming over
you might let things slide a little bit
and get a little bit messy and i
definitely did that with this project
and i wish that i didn't at first you do
everything
quickly and you think oh not having a
naming convention won't really matter in
the long run this is only going to be a
short project anyway she says and then a
year later
you're gonna be confusing me like where
did i put this again i'm pretty sure
i've already made an
actor like this before and um
it causes more headaches than it's worth
use folders and group actors within the
world outliner create a clean and
understandable
folder structure create naming
conventions
all of the good stuff all of the good
stuff and
finally it has really really really
shown me that i
need to upgrade from a laptop
to a proper pc so you'll be happy to
hear that i have finally finally
bought myself all the parts i need to
put together a pc
unfortunately i am waiting oh wait
should i find out which graphics card
i'm
getting unfortunately i am still
waiting on my graphics card which is
a geforce rtx 307
oh i still don't really know much about
hardware i just rely on my friends that
do
and it's not gonna come for a while
because i
am number 215
in the queue i hope i get this pc before
christmas
but i'm so glad that i have bought
a new pc and i know it will be here for
next year at least
and definitely by the time the unreal
engine 5 comes along because with all
those crazy triangles
i don't think my little laptop would be
able to handle them
and now that i've talked so much i think
i can't talk anymore
so if you have reached the end of this
video then
thank you so much for watching i really
hope it's been
educational if not educational i hope
it's been somewhat entertaining or at
least
interesting i have actually written a
whole article on everything that i
learnt
and the mistakes that i've made so i
will put that down in the link below
this has been a massive massive learning
lesson for me
and i can't wait to work on more
projects like it in the future
if you have any feedback for me from the
short film
or even any projects that i've done
in the past that perhaps you'd like to
see me dabble more in
then do let me know i am excited
just to to spend more time working on
the projects that i
really feel passionate about and those
are ones where i get to tell stories and
in particular
dark stories i i do like the darkness
thanks again for watching really
appreciate you being here as always
also you can catch me every thursday at
around
9pm gmt where i livestream on the
channel
so i hope to see you there have a lovely
video evening
bye
[Music]
it was extremely hard just to be able to
view the floor where i wanted to
so you'll see back in environment two
um the floor isn't you can't really
see it very well but you can just in
front of the car and that
is not actually because of these
spotlights because i've got spotlights
here for the car
well these are point lights but i've got
point lights for the area
so that you can see a little bit of the
car and i've got
spotlights to light up what's in front
of it
and then actually i've got a wrecked
light which i've been using
all over the place they've been
extremely useful